okay go ahead so here we go so a
computer program is essentially the
collection of entities and actions on
those entities and the kinds of entities
I'm talking about are things like in C
functions objects constants types in C++
wheels have namespaces templates in fact
if you look in the standard there's an
even larger list in the C++ standard of
the sort of things but you get the idea
when I talk about an entity and one of
the essential things that you do in
programs is that you write declarations
for entities and when you do that you
give the entity a name and a bunch of
other attributes those attributes are
things like type scope storage duration
and linkage and what I want to do is
talk about scope storage duration and
linkage and why it is that they're so
jumbled together in the language and
what you can do to help clarify this so
one key point is that names don't
necessarily have all the attributes it
depends on the category of the entity so
for example an object as all of those
things it has a scope a type a storage
duration and linkage a function name has
everything except it doesn't have a
storage duration there's no notion of a
function occupying data storage and
having a lifetime the way an object does
one of the least-used labor categories
is a label when you write a go-to
statement which I hope is very
infrequently you have to have a
statement label statement labels don't
have any of the attributes except a
scope so a declaration is a statement
there was a time way back when when C
was first specified the declarations and
statements were considered to be
distinct things now a declaration is
actually considered to be just another
kind of statement you can interleave
them in blocks with other action
statements what is a declaration it says
basically here's a name and a bunch of
attributes for something that exists in
the program possibly here possibly
somewhere else a definition is a
declaration that not only says
it exists but here it is all definitions
or declarations but not all declarations
or definitions so simple example that's
a function declaration now a lot of
people will call that a function
prototype you'll note I'm not going to
use that word other than to tell you
don't use it it actually has a different
meaning that when most of you think it
means that's a function declaration
that's a function definition the
difference is the previous one didn't
have a function body this one does and
basically the definition is whether it's
a function the functions are the easy
ones to understand but whether it's a an
object or a template or a class the
definition is here's everything you need
to know about it in order to make this
thing real so once again a non defining
declaration for a function says it
exists but not here the definition says
it exists and here it is and that's
generally true with other things like
objects it's generally true with classes
and templates as well in C++
interestingly there's just like in C++
there is this notion of a pure virtual
function there's no official term for an
impure virtual function well similarly
with the terminology of declarations and
definitions there isn't any terminology
in either C or C++ that says this is a
declaration that is not a definition you
have so you'll notice that I have to
keep repeating the awkward phrase a non
defining declaration because that's the
best I could do now another point that I
think most of you know but it is notice
that I'm emphasizing this is compilers
translate one source file at a time they
don't you don't compile headers you only
compile sources and you do one at a time
and and when you compile it whether it's
C or C++ you're incorporating headers
via include directives and this is
important there aren't any rules if you
read both the sea and the C++ standards
there aren't any rules which say
explicitly these constructs have to go
into headers these constructs have to go
into source files and and you'll see why
that is in just a moment but what they
do is they leave it to programmers to
develop a sense of how to do this and
style guidelines will try their best
sometimes to tell you to give you some
concrete guidance on this but I have yet
to see a set of style guidelines which
is really that useful with respect to
this stuff it still comes down to
there's no substitute for just
understanding the problems that you face
and being able to make the judgments and
it turns out that a lot of being able to
make those judgments depends on
understanding scope linkage and storage
duration and how they interact now the
as you well know the initial phase of
translation in both C and C++ is running
this thing called the preprocessor the
preprocessor is what handles header file
inclusion macro substitution conditional
compilation like hash if and hash else
and stuff like that but this is the key
term translation unit just out of
curiosity how many of you are already
familiar with this term translation unit
okay this is this is a major insight if
you read the standard you will see that
in fact this term is used considerably
more than the terms header files and
source files and that a way to picture
what's happening is that the compiler
whether it's C or C++ takes your source
file and the first thing it does is it
runs it through that portion of the
compiler known as the preprocessor and
you can think of it as if the
preprocessor is a separate program which
spits out another source file then that
source file has a name it's called a
translation unit
essentially a translation unit is the
result of running a C or C++ source file
through the preprocessor and spitting
out a new source file in which all of
the preprocessor directives have been
processed all the includes have been
done all the conditional ifs and else's
have been handled and now in fact most
compilers commercially available
compilers have compile options to say
pre process only if you want to debug a
macro you want to check that your
conditionals are being handled properly
you can actually say give me a
intermediate source file pre process
only and often the extension that you
see on that file is dot I or a I and in
fact most C and C++ compilers will
accept one of those source files as the
input you can actually say here's a file
that has already been pre processed and
the compiler knows what to do with it it
knows not the pre process at any further
and just run it through the rest of the
compiler and so the reason why
translation units are so important is
because many of the semantic rules
regarding things like linkage and
storage duration are not expressed in
terms of headers and source files but
they are expressed in terms of
translation units some of you may be
familiar with c++ has this famous rule
known as the OD are the one definition
rule and that stuff's all expressed in
terms of translation units not in terms
of headers and source files but it still
comes back that you're understanding
about what's going on affects what you
decide to put into a header and what you
decide to put into a source file then
again most of the insights come from
understanding the difference between a
declaration and a definition a non
defining declaration and a defining
declaration linkage and storage duration
and that's where we're headed so with
that little recap oh there's one other
thing I want to talk about which is that
the compiler transforms each translation
unit in
an object file also known as an object
module and then it takes a collection of
object files along with possibly
previously compiled object files that
may be in the form of libraries links
them together and produces an executable
now an executable program most compilers
have the option of producing executables
which are release builds or debug builds
and I'm going to focus most of my
attention on the release ones the debug
builds are essentially release builds
with a whole bunch of extra stuff thrown
in for debugging purposes I'm just gonna
focus on the release build properties so
what's in a typical object file of a
release built well there's two main
pieces now I'm painting in broad strokes
here that the details of course are a
little bit more intricate than this but
for the most part what you see in an
object file the cut the information
content falls into two broad categories
data and metadata what's the data well
the data is things like machine
instructions turning your assignment
statements and to moves loads and stores
and your comparisons and death into
comparison Asteria if equal or while not
equal loops into compares and branches
that's the machine instructions part and
then there could be values anytime you
define storage for example a brace
initialized array that's going to become
data that goes into the object file the
metadata falls into two broad categories
and that is and this is this is key
right now we're gonna really build on
this part right here which is that
function names and object names can wind
up as metadata in the object files now
what do I mean by metadata
it's that remember what the linker is
going to do is take a bunch of these
object files and try to weave them
together to produce an executable which
is then a bunch of ones and zeros which
loaded into memory to execute by the
time it gets loaded into memory things
even like function names and the names
of data objects are gone it's just a
bunch of machine instructions and bit
patterns for data but the linker has to
use this stuff in order to be able to
take to object modules in which there's
compiled code for example for a function
code call over here calling a function
that's actually defined over there
somehow or another the linker needs that
information and so the function and
object names are often known as Deaf's
and refs they are the definitions of
things like functions and objects and
they are references to things like
functions and objects and the linkers
job is to make them talk to each other
and once it figures out numerically
where those addresses are it says I
don't need that information and throws
it away
it doesn't wind up in the executable
itself there's also stuff that guides
the linking program section names it's
very common that code will be collected
together into one logical section so
that if you have code in one object file
and code in another object file in the
bound program they will become
physically contiguous and similarly data
in one object file and data in another
will be woven together by the linker so
the data will be physically contiguous
often and that's done through the notion
of logical sections but for our
discussion that that part of the
metadata isn't that important ok so now
let's talk for a moment about scope so I
said I was gonna talk about three
attributes scope storage duration and
linkage a fundamental activity within
the compiler is as it sees declarations
the declarations have attributes
associated with them and that attribute
information is important for two things
one is it it's the information the
compiler uses to validate is the name
being used correctly when it's being
used in a context and the other part of
the attribute is
and what do I do to generate code for it
so the declarations the primary effect
of a declaration is to take information
and put it into this internal structure
known as the symbol table when the
compiler later sees the use of that name
in the same translation unit it will
look it up and find out is the name
declared what are the attributes is this
use of the name consistent with the
prior declaration or is there a conflict
between this use and the attributes that
would provoke a compiler complaint and
so the names are broken in distributing
their into regions called scope and in
and essentially your informal
understanding is scope is a curly
bracket at region of text it's not
exactly that but that's most of our most
of us get by with that informal
understanding in C there are two kinds
of scope regions there's actually
there's four of them
but the other corner cases are not even
worth wasting any time on there's block
scope and there's file scope and
basically block scope is the curly
bracket or block with the exception that
when you're dealing with functions block
scope includes names in the parameter
list of a function definition they are
considered to be at the same scope level
as local variables at the outermost
block and a function which is why you
can't name a local variable the same as
a parameter and then there's file scope
which is anything that is in block scope
anything outside of a function structure
Union interestingly those of how many of
you program and see oh what fair number
of you very interesting phenomenon this
is again language lawyering which is not
worth laboring over a lot but C does not
have the notion of structure scope we
often think of the names in a structure
as being in their own scope but that is
not the formalism
you see when you read the C standard
they actually say that each structure
forms its own namespace which is an
alternate phrasing but the net effect is
that structure scope in sorry structure
namespaces in C or almost the same in
behavior as if they were their own scope
but like for example one of the curious
things about the structure namespace in
C is that you cannot declare things like
types in a structure well you know what
happens if you do that does anyone know
if you actually put a type def or an
enumeration definition inside the curly
braces of a struct do you know what
happens say C programmers don't even go
there you do this all the time in C++
but in C all it does is it takes that
definition and treats it as if it were
in the enclosing scope of the structured
definition in other words you try to put
it there and immediately it just gets
dragged out one level structures are not
their own scope and see that's why I
don't bring that up here in C++ what C
calls block scope and file scope is
actually called global and local scope
in C++ and I believe these are more
popular terms even C programmers will
use these terms in preference to file
scope and block scope and that's so
that's the way I'm going to do it since
I'm trying to talk about both C and C++
here I'm going to use the C++
terminology C++ adds class scope and
namespace scope with these interesting
notes first of all in C++ classes
structures and unions are all the same
thing a struct is just a class in which
all of the members are public by default
and a union is just a struct in which
all the members are at offset zero but
otherwise they behave according to the
same rules
and in C++ namespace scope is a
generalization of the global scope that
essentially glow the global scope in C++
is just treated as another namespace and
you will see examples of that very
shortly but there's enough similarities
between what's going on with namespace
scope in C++ and the global scope in C I
can talk about them as if they're all
behaving according to consistent rules
okay now here is a biggie this is one of
the key points of this talk well
everything else was leading up to that
which is that the concept of scope
applies only to a single translation
unit each one translation unit at a time
there is no such thing as global scope
which somehow escapes a translation unit
into the program at large okay that's
the myth that I see in a lot of articles
and just you know online discussions
about C and C++ as they talk as if there
is something beyond the scope of a
single translation unit and there isn't
because a scope is just a region of text
in a translation unit in this in a
source and a header file that's all it
is
nothing higher than that so how is it
that a name used in one translation unit
can refer to the same the name with the
same spelling in another translation and
the answer is it does it with linkage
and so I want to make these distinctions
really clear as to what's going on and
give you what I think is a fairly
accurate conceptual model of how this
happens within the compiler and how it
affects the way you organize things so
once again you know the problem is a lot
of programmers have trouble separating
scope storage duration linkage and
that's because the language tries to get
by both C and C plus
do this with probably arguably too few
keywords in particular the keywords
static has been stretched to the
breaking point in C++ and I'll show you
what I mean by that
so from a language perspective this is
largely driven by these keywords in the
language known as storage class
specifiers if Auto X turns register
static thread-local and type def that's
the current set in C now a couple of
things to know one of them is
thread-local is actually not a key word
and tomorrow I'm going to be giving a
talk on called new features in C and I'm
going to explain the underlying
philosophy of why C does what I'm
showing you here is but actually the key
word is underscore capital T
thread-local that's the reserved word
thread-local itself with the lowercase T
no leading underscore is actually a
macro and you can only use it by
including a header first type def is not
really a storage class either the
grammar of the C language throws type
def in with these others simply as a
syntactic convenience and there's
actually a footnote in the standard that
says that this is a little it's a
grammatical hack they don't use that
term just to make the grammar a little
bit easier to write but type def is not
a storage class really C++ provides
these four extern mutable static and
thread-local there is some overlap
mutable is used only in the declaration
of class members and it's a way of
essentially nullifying constant asst and
it again it's put in with the storage
classes but it's arguable that it
doesn't really behave like the other
storage classes in the way that I'm
about to show you
what happened to Otto that was back
there in the list from C Otto has been a
storage class specifier in C since C was
Z back in 1972 and nobody uses it and
that's because the only valid place for
using the keyword Otto in C is to
declare a local variable and the default
if you don't put the Otto there is Otto
in other words so Otto is a keyword
whose only use is to restate a default
and do nothing else it's pretty useless
so C++ said well since it's so useless
we have a need for a keyword and we
don't want to invent a new one they
actually stole it in C++ and made it a
type specifier how about register what
happened to that register is still a
keyword in C and but it says the meaning
is it's mostly it says it's
implementation to find meaning it's up
to what the compiler wants to do with it
and there's a footnote that says and the
intent is it's supposed to speed things
up in some way well the in C++ the
attitude is hey come on optimizers do
better than you can and so it's it's
been that way for at least twenty years
now that C++ compilers have been
ignoring the key word register and so
now the status of register in C++ is
it's still a keyword and it has no
meaning
that's simply they say it's a keyword
with no meaning it will be repurposed
sometime in the next decade that's
what's going to happen with it I believe
the only difference in C with register
is there may be some subtleties about
you can't take the address of a register
object but other than that it behaves
just like an auto so let's focus our
attention on these three these are the
three that are common to C and C++ and
there's a
to create enough examples to show the
distinction between linkage storage
duration now the rule is that most one
storage class specifier can appear on a
declaration with one exception and that
exception is thread-local is allowed to
appear with extern or static so you can
have external ocol or static
thread-local but otherwise you can only
have one of these and there are some
declarations where this stuff just isn't
permitted at all for example you're not
allowed to use the keyword extern in
either C or C++ to declare the member of
a struct or class that's not valid now
there are contexts in which the presence
or absence of a particular keyword has
no effect right there those two are the
same thing
add or remove that X turn the program's
behavior doesn't change at all and this
is true for both C and C++ in both cases
that is defining an object named n whose
initial value is 42 and if this appears
at global scope or namespace scope and
C++ they behave exactly the same on the
other hand most of the time when you do
put a storage class specifier on a
declaration expect it to have an effect
in particular with those two at the
bottom the first one has the explicit
presence of extern that turns that
declaration into a non defining
declaration says this is not a
definition for n this is saying there is
an N and it's somewhere else but the
second one says there's an N and here it
is and again this is true in both C and
C++
when this appears at non class scope
so what's the underlying principle
behind that distinction between extern
or no extern it's that for object C with
functions we saw earlier the distinction
between a declaration that's not a
definition and a definition is the
presence or absence of a function body
in with objects there isn't a simple
syntactic specification that says this
one is a declaration not quite as clear
as is that but as you'll see in a moment
it's almost as clear but the underlying
concept is that an object definition is
going to allocate storage and an object
and a non defining declaration is not
it's going to say it's somewhere else so
the C++ rule for definitions outside of
a class is right there in in bold it
says that a definition the declaration
is a definition unless it has the
keyword extern and no initializer so
that first one lacks an extern notice it
doesn't have initializer it died but it
also lacks extern that's a definition
that allocates storage for I what's its
initial value anyone know what's the
initial value pardon
yes if well if it if it's if it occurs
outside of a block it's actually defined
behavior that it's zero and that's
that's just not a quirk of some compiler
that is a specification of both the sea
and the C++ standards that statically
that's actually I just jumped ahead it
has the property that that thing is
statically allocated which I'll get to
in a moment statically allocated objects
are zeroed that at programs start up and
that's that is a well specified feature
now for local variables that's why you
are hesitating local variables there's
the the official term is it has an
indeterminate value which is a polite
way of saying it's whatever stray bits
we're in there from some previous use of
that storage the second one of these
extern int J that's the way you write a
declaration for an object in C++ to
guarantee that it's just a declaration
and then the last one is a definition
because although it has extern it has an
initializer which says hey I can't can't
put an initial value there unless I'm
also allocating the storage so what are
the implications of this well if you
want to you know what you'll see in a
moment is that there are real problems
putting the first one or the last one in
a header file only that only the one in
the middle can safely be placed in
header files in general now the rules in
C are a bit more complicated than this
but if you follow this C++ rule it will
work perfectly in C you see has some
more intricate wording that allows a
little bit more slop and I just
encourage people just follow the C++
rules whether you're in C++ or C and you
won't go wrong you will not have con
flicks now here's what makes static
particularly troublesome one is that
sometimes it affects the way programs
allocate storage other times it affects
the way object files link together and
then in C++ it turns out that can alter
the behavior of a class member function
that the keyword static doesn't change
the storage allocation it doesn't change
the linkage properties it only changes
the parameter list of a function in a
subtle way so remember this about class
storage specifiers which is that they
affect linkage and storage duration of
names but they don't affect scope so
what I've used this term storage
duration now let's dive in talk about a
little bit about what it is it's that it
affects the lifetime of an object its
how does the the runtime system of a
program manage the storage for an object
by the way this is a property only of
objects not of functions not of data
types but of objects and the four type
the four kinds of storage of duration
are static thread automatic and dynamic
in thread is relatively new that was
added in C++ 11 and in C 11 so what a
static storage means it means basically
the storage for the object is allocated
when the program starts and the object
stays where it is in place for the
entire execution of the program and goes
away well after the program is done
running you don't care whether it goes
away or not thread storage duration is
there's a real similarity between that
and static the only difference is that
it's the duration of the execution of a
thread thread starts up if it has thread
local storage that thread-local storage
will be allocated at that time it may
have been set aside prior to the start
of the thread conceptually
you only have access to it until the
thread starts running and it's there as
long as the thread remains running
automatic this is the stuff that's
typically local to a block right inside
a curly bracket and function body or a
block nested therein and the storage is
allocated when the block begins now just
a brief aside is that a function
functions can have blocks within them
and there can be declarations within
those curly bracket and bodies does the
runtime system wait until it enters a
block to actually allocate that storage
or does it is it allowed to do it
earlier and a lot of compilers will
actually look at all the nested blocks
and figure out how much storage do I
need for the most deeply nested for the
outermost block and that most deeply
nested one and it will allocate all of
that a Punk function entry and it may be
that some of that stuff in the stack
doesn't get used but the concept is
though that that storage isn't allocated
until you actually cross over the curly
bracket 'add body and enter that block
and conceptually it goes away when you
exit that block but it may be that it
waits until it actually returns from the
function to actually D allocate it from
the stack because that's often more
efficient from a performance standpoint
dynamic this is the stuff that you do
manually and see it would be commonly
with malloc calloc realloc functions
like that and free in C++ it's typically
operator new and operator delete and
there are lots of different flavors of
operator new and delete in within C++
but it's a manual operation and you're
carving up a pool of memory often known
as in C it's called the heap and C++
it's called the free store and now
linkage this is the most interesting one
essentially linkage is the property that
a name can have which allows a name to
be declared in more than one place and
have those two declarations wind up
referring to the same entity that's what
linkage is and there are actual and
there are three kinds of linkage
external internal and no linkage we're
going to go through each of these in
some detail and then drum roll turns out
C++ is going to add it's now in the the
new specification of C++ C++ 20 has a
feature called modules and modules the
intent is to eventually replace they use
some header files use it with a
different scheme for doing separate
compilation that frees us from some of
the tyranny of the preprocessor and so
in order to support the semantics of
modules there's now another kind of
linkage called module linkage now
modules are a whole nother lecture so
other than to mention that this is
coming down the road I'm going to stick
with the other three that'll take a the
available time we have anyway but my one
of the things that I want to suggest is
that those of you who are going to be
working in C++ what you want to do as
you a tackle your new understanding of
modules is apply the kind of stuff that
I'm talking about here as the under make
sure that you have an good underlying
model of what modulars are doing in
terms of storage duration and linkage
because that's where the key insights
are gonna you're gonna see a lot of
tutorials that will just say don't worry
just do this do this do this and it'll
work and there's a lot of that goes on
in C and C++ and for the most part
people learn to program and C by not
worrying about it until it bites them
right and then you got to really figure
out what's going on here and and and and
this is the model the kind of model you
need
okay so external linkage is when you can
have a name declared in two completely
separate translation units the same name
but at length time those two names
become one so the external means that's
the way you cross one translation unit
boundary this is what's really happening
when people tell you that that when you
put the word static it takes it from
being this super global scope down to
just being a module level scope well
they're really trying to avoid telling
you that what the real machinery that
does this is external linkage that's
that's really what's going on and so
here we have a total an object called
total which is defined and file1 its but
notice it's it's got the keyword X turn
on which says it has external linkage
but that is a definition it does have an
initial value equals 0 in the second
translation unit file 2 it says X turn
in total that does not have an
initializer so that's just a non
defining declaration those two things
become one after separately compiling
each of those you link them together
there's only one total in this program
compare that with internal linkage names
with internal linkage can be declared
multiple times within a single
translation unit and they all wind up
referring to the same thing but they
can't refer but nobody outside the
translation unit can refer to those
things with internal linkage so here in
file 1 we have total now declared with
the keyword static that's not just a
declaration that's it's a definition for
total with internal linkage and in the
other file you have a declan on defining
declaration with external linkage
and that says hey I don't have any
storage I need it from somewhere else
but it can't get it from file one file
one does not have external linkage they
these things the linker can't make them
become one so if you want this probe by
the way if you try to build this program
because that's an unsatisfied reference
in file two you would probably get a
link error at that link time it would
say I don't see a definition for total
to satisfy that and you say well can I
get out of file one the answer is no
because file one doesn't know that that
total does not have external linkage so
what you need is a third one there you
need to have file three has a definition
for a total so that the one in file two
can refer to the one in file three now
the program will build and how many
totals are there in this program there
are two of them one internal to file one
and one that's shared by file two and
file three shared via external linkage
then there's the concept of no linkage
local variables have no linkage you have
two functions F and G they each have a
local variable name total but think
about it is there any way you can write
a declaration for total anywhere else in
the program that will at linked time
become a reference to one of those
totals that's inside the function body
no thief those totals have automatic
storage they are not statically
allocated because they don't have a
fixed location there's no way that the
linker can say oh I know how to link to
that thing because that thing doesn't
have a guaranteed spot at runtime
the only things that can have linkage
are things that have fixed locations
functions and objects with static
storage so here's a good conceptual
model of what's happening is that names
that have external linkage our names
that are passed on to the linker in a
release build names that have internal
linkage and no linkage are useful if
you're doing symbolic debugging but the
linker doesn't use them when it is
combining object files together to
produce an executable so names defined
with external linkage in a translation
you to become deaths definitions in the
compiled object file names declared with
external linkage but not defined become
refs essentially add F in an object file
says I've got an externally defined name
and I'm making it available for other
people to refer to it a ref says my
translation unit needs this thing I'm
mentioning this name but I don't have a
definition for it I need to get it from
somewhere else those things are passed
on into the object files with if they
have external linkage and for the most
part the compiler discards names that
are declared with internal or no linkage
they don't make their way into the
release build object files okay so let's
look at some examples here you know by
default functions which are at file
scope in C have external linkage by
default so most of the behaviors you're
about to see are things you're gonna nod
yeah I see this and this model that
you're giving me fits but I think it's
worth illustrating them with a few
examples the same thing will happen if
you put names at namespace scope in C++
adding the word extern on a function
declaration has no effect for a function
that's at global scope or in a namespace
in C++ whether you put the X turn there
and not the behavior is the same class
members in C++ have external linkage by
default you know those of you who do
program in C++ know that you commonly
place class definitions in header files
and you include those all over the place
and create objects of that type and call
member functions on them and at nowhere
did you say these things were extern you
just treat them as if they are they have
external linkage by default and if you
explicitly put the word extra in there
the compiler says no I got it covered
you have no choice about it its external
so you can't even restate the default in
C++
now when you declare a function with the
keyword static all that does is change
the linkage functions don't have a
storage duration so the only thing that
this is doing is changing the linkage
properties gives it internal linkage but
with C++ classes there are these things
called static member functions and as I
stated a moment ago class members in C++
always have external linkage and this
static doesn't change that even these
things called static member functions
still have external linkage what happens
is it changes the parameter list in AC
in C++ class member functions have an
implicitly generated parameter called
this and what the keyword static does on
a function is it tells to the compiler
take away this pointer from this
function which seems like what static
does that
it turns out it's it's actually because
that makes sense given what a static
data member is that static member
functions are used for manipulating
static data members and static data
members turn out that's not such an
outrageous thing to call them that in
C++
now objects that file our namespace
scope always have static storage
duration it doesn't matter what keyword
you put in front of them if it's global
or if it's in a namespace they always
have static storage duration what is the
static or extern do it changes the
linkage so let me just as an aside here
the key point I'm trying to make is the
real insight into what's going on in C
and C++ with respect to objects and
functions is to understand there are
these three attributes scope storage
duration and linkage and the keywords
can you really lead you astray because
if you're talking to somebody else you
can just say I have a static object here
what does that really mean are you
talking about something with static
storage are you talking about something
with external linkage and static storage
are you talking about something with
internal linkage the way to clarify your
conversations with your colleagues is to
use the underlying attribute when you
talk about the property of the thing and
and make it and then understand that the
way it got there was through the
appropriate use of the keywords extern
and Static and the proper placement in
scope objects at local scope can have
almost any storage duration as well in
that notice that the first one has
static and the second one are both
static storage duration the third one
has Auto storage duration notice that
question mark behind the word external
there because extern actually has a
curious behavior which is it extern
doesn't always mean external linkage
and let me show you the example here
which is that the actual rule in both C
and C++ one which you should not I'm
showing you this more for entertainment
value than anything else I would not
take advantage of this very much in your
programming but a name declared extern
has internal linkage if it was
previously declared in the translation
unit with internal linkage the the
illustration here is notice I have foo
is defined to be or declared to be a
function with internal linkage in this
translation unit and then I come down
into main and I say X turn int foo and
that X turn doesn't give it external
linkage it looks and says oh you
previously had internal linkage you
still have internal linkage now
declaring functions locally like that
that's all left over from from C which
most of us don't do anymore right but it
turns out that when you read the
standard to find out what extern mean
the it doesn't just say external linkage
. there's this extra verbiage for a
feature you don't want but here's a
couple other things linkage also
explains a subtle behavioral difference
within a couple ways with with the
constant objects as you well know you
know this the traditional way and see of
handling symbolic constants is to use
macros this is discouraged very much in
C++ because in they don't observe the
scope rules macros because they're
handled by the preprocessor and the
preprocessor doesn't know any the
preprocessor thinks like curly brace is
just an interesting looking character it
has no semantic value to the
preprocessor and so whereas with other
kinds of entities you can have local
things local to a function where in C++
you can put him in namespaces or classes
you can't do
that with a macro and so C++ looked for
ways to avoid using macros for this
purpose and came up with using constant
objects now these things exist not only
in C++ but they were actually in C as
well the history by the way is that they
started out in C++ and then they got
brought over into C and this C committee
decided for whatever reasons to change
the semantics so that they don't quite
work the same in both languages and it
turns out linkage is part of the
difference and so I'll just show you so
anyway you can have constant objects of
an integer type of a floating type of a
pointer type and they observe the scope
rules here's the key thing is that
there's this concept in both C and C++
of what's called a constant expression
constant expressions appear in a number
of places like for example when you
specify a bit field the width of a bit
field has to be it can be a symbolic
constant but it has to be a constant
whose value is known at compile time and
that code right there compiles in C++
but not C because the C compiler does
not regard max there as a symbolic
constant whose value is known at compile
time it says this is an object which
happens to have a 16 in it but I have to
act as if I don't know that the value is
always 16 which makes symbolic constants
in C considerably less useful than they
are in C++ and so the difference is that
in C they have external linkage by
default so if you were to do this where
you put a symbolic constant in one
source file in and in another like that
you'd actually get linked errors that
code will compile both translation units
and then fail at linked time because the
symbol sum is multiply defined
but in C++ in order to make it
convenient to use these things as
symbolic constants they said okay we're
gonna give these things internal linkage
Const objects have internal linkage by
default in C++ so that you can just have
a symbolic constant and have its value
known and you can also know that nobody
in another translation unit is linking
to it to screw up the known value at
compile time and so this makes it
feasible to do this to take this is the
common thing is to be able to take a
symbolic constant definition like that
put it in a header file and include it
in multiple translation units which is
the way you'd like to treat a symbolic
constant and it works in C++ because
when you include the header in each of
those places some has internal linkage
each translation unit has its own copy
that nobody else can see now in this
case they all have a copy of something
with the same value which is very useful
but the compiler can do can do all kinds
of nice compile time analysis on it that
it can't do as easily in C because the
linkage gets in the way so the problem
is that if you take this same code and
compile as whoops my battery died here
can I use the cursor key here is there
on this unit that you covered up the
cursor keys what should I use page up
and page down or
use that okay oh oh okay
it wasn't like clique or something at my
did time out okay anyway so there that's
what happened was if you do this in C
then that thing with internal linkage up
there could become sex sternal linkage
now you get the same name with external
linkage in both translation units and it
doesn't build last thing inline
functions what's the behavior of those
well well how many here you familiar
with in lines okay you know in lining
says what I'd like the compiler to do is
substitute the body of the function at
the point of the call but it's not a
guarantee you know this substituting the
body the function at the point of the
call is the desired behavior but not a
guarantee that it is possible that the
compiler will decide for various reasons
I'm going to translate it into a non
inline call and so what happens then
oh so the consequence is by the way that
with with normal non inline functions
you declare them in a header and define
them in a C or CPP file but with inline
functions you actually put the entire
function definition in the header that's
so that the function definition is
visible at the point of the call and
then the problem is that's now a
definition of it of a function with
external linkage if it's not in lined
you're gonna have multiply defined
symbols but if it's in lined it's okay
and now but what happens if the compiler
says but I'm not going to in line
because in lighting is only a request
it's not a mandate what will happen is
the compiler will compile non inline
calls
into calls with external linkage and it
will then say the the copy that I
generate of the non inline function
there will only be one and everybody
goes to the same spot so so the when
they talk about inline functions having
linkage if it's always in line there's
never a function to talk to but when
it's not in line that you're guaranteed
there's one and only one copy and
linkage again is a key part of that
explanation okay so that's it in summary
here the key points is the storage class
specifiers extern and static don't
affect scope they affect these other
properties called storage duration and
linkage or in C++ they can affect a
parameter list of a static member
function the scope the concept of scope
is only meaningful in a single
translation unit there's no scope beyond
a single translation unit and the key
thing that allows to translation units
to communicate with each other is that
the names in them have external linkage
and if you remember those key points
most of the rest of this stuff makes an
awful lot more sense I hope that was
helpful thanks very much for being here
[Applause]